[Music]
Oprah Winfrey made her first million in
1986 the same year her namesake show
launched nationally in just one year
after making her feature film debut in
the color purple forbes first wrote
about Oprah's success and her talk show
in 1987 while most celebrities at the
time had support staff including
publicists a personal manager business
manager and agent all of whom took
percentages of earnings Oprah did not
she said giving away 40% is insane and
delegated just one person Jeffery Jacobs
to handle everything she invested her
early earnings into a 100,000 square
foot 20 million dollar production
facility which spanned an entire block
of the west side of Chicago and with the
creation of this new production house
called Harpo Productions she gained
complete ownership over the show all the
jobs that were typically handled by
outsiders Winfrey brought in-house
hiring her own team to do the work of
traditional marketing firms on-air
promotional services post production
houses and more this lean strategy made
Oprah self-sufficient and able the tape
shows whenever she wanted
Harpo Entertainment Group quickly turned
into an entertainment conglomerate
producing her daily talk show as well as
feature films and TV movies and she was
just getting started by 1995 she was
sitting on an estimated 340 million
dollar fortune enough to join the Forbes
400 list of richest Americans and
becoming the first black woman to ever
appear on the list in 1997 she grew that
fortune into 550 million dollars and in
2003 Oprah became a billionaire after 25
years of Oprah being on the air she said
goodbye to her TV show and in
partnership with Discovery
Communications launched her own cable
channel The Oprah Winfrey Network or
owned in 2011
her 25.5% share of the network is worth
about 70 million dollars in 2015
Winfrey bought ten percent of Weight
Watchers but she has since donated some
of the shares to her charitable
foundations and sold some and now owns a
seven percent stake plus options to
purchase more shares today Winfrey has a
net worth of 2.6 billion dollars the
rest of her fortune is mostly made up of
profits from television network own
payments from WW formerly Weight
Watchers and her deal with Hearst to
produce Oh The Oprah Magazine